hey guys i want to address something
i've been noticing and kind of
going through mentally for many years
now is i've been trying to kind of make
it as a content
creator from many different angles and
generally haven't succeeded and
maybe finally might be starting to to
crack a little bit of
success here and there but even still
some of these problems still
apply quite greatly and i'll dress them
as they come up and
i want to be clear about a few things in
this video as you've probably already
seen the title know what it's about
this is not to bash people that have
made it
congrats to you if you have that's
awesome this is more about
how hard it is as a new creator to
even like break any sort of new ground
or get anywhere
and how much just the enormous amount of
work it takes
so i think probably a minority of people
are probably
guilty of being on the problem side of
this
you know the non-content creator as the
watcher uh
because well we'll get to that it's it's
about how things are pushed
so the main point here and it's kind of
hard to
discern how this affects everyone since
it's it's can be different for everyone
but it's more about uh
it's more about how i've experienced it
so that's
that's how we're going to talk about it
all right so i've kind of noticed it's
very
very hard to grow nearly impossible or
well so maybe you can grow but you grow
at such a slow
rate that it's not a reasonable path to
success
so you can kind of look at your trend
line and say oh look in 15
years i'll make enough to pay my bills
or in 20 years i'll make enough
which isn't a reasonable career path you
need a job where you can pay your bills
month to month in general not
not in 15 years that doesn't really work
for for most people
so that that's kind of one of the things
i want to address here
and the last thing i want to kind of
cover is what is a new person
to do how do you get past this how do
you actually grow
as a content creator all right so here
we go let's dive into it
the pre famous problem
all right so the thing here is that if
you've already
made it you've you're already famous
you're
pretty famous going into something then
you have no problem continuing you can
do
pretty much anything you can want you
can make any kickstarter you can want
you can start any project you want
and it's almost automatically successful
no matter how bad you do at it
you can still get the initial funding
you can still find all your supporters
from before and
that's not necessarily a bad thing you
know that's actually probably a good
thing it's really nice once you're at
that level
to say that it's a problem is kind of a
weird thing it's not
it's it's more of a problem for the new
guy it's for someone that has a great
idea
but no one to listen to them or for
someone who really wants to have do
something
but it has really hard uh problem
you know a lot of trouble getting people
to jump on board or to find initial
funding
all right so the ones who have made it
are pushed if you look at youtube the
videos that already get a ton of views
the creators that already get a ton of
views and have tons of subs
they're the ones who at the top of the
list when you visit it as a new user
or just some generic user the videos
they want you to watch
are the ones from people that have
already made it right
and for example for my videos do they
push my new videos not very much but
once
my videos get a lot of views then it
keeps getting more views but the ones
who don't get any views they never get
any more views
so it's like they only push the ones
that have already made it
i might have a really good video that no
one's watched
maybe i don't know you never know right
because no one's ever going to recommend
it
because it didn't get much speaking with
that sort of thing that's what i'm
talking about
that's not just me it happens to every
everyone and if you go to twitch
you'll recommend it like the top 10
streamers and that's it
watch the top 10 streamers they have
thousands upon thousands of viewers
but then there's so many streamers that
have pretty much snow viewers like one
to five one to ten
five to ten and they might have really
really good satisfying streams
but it's not going to get pushed until
thousands of people pile on and actually
that's how it gets pushed it gets pushed
by
being famous so it's it's like a paradox
of
you can't make it until you've already
made it
and that paradox for some reason bothers
me and i'm going to try to get to the
solutions
of this there's not there's not an exact
solution because it's not exactly
a problem per se it's more like a
hypothetical problem for a new person
who would like to rise the ranks not
just it's probably good for other people
because they want to see
content that's been weeded out they just
don't want to go see all the
stuff from new creators that's not
necessarily all that great you know
all right so let's move to the second
part here and this this is uh
this is something i see a lot and it's
an issue of maybe people finally find
you but they see
they want to see social validation they
don't particularly care about the
content
or you or anything all they want to see
is that other people like you and this
this really bothers me more than any
anything it's like okay so i'm going to
jump on the bandwagon that's
the mentality that they take if other
people like this person i like them if
other people don't like this person
i don't like them or this creator or
whatever it may be and that's the stance
they don't they don't really critique
the content they might not even
i don't know they might watch the
content and have a meh indifferent
opinion
and then they want to see what other
people are doing and they jump on that
bandwagon i'm not a big
fan of bandwagon hopping as you as you
can probably tell i don't
tend to make videos on trending subjects
or anything because i just don't care i
try to make
videos on things that i want to do or
that i find important or things that
don't seem to be out there
and or you know i feel like i'm trying
to do things that
need to be done not necessarily that are
the trend so and i
know already that i could probably grow
a lot faster by jumping on trends and
and doing all these things i'm saying i
don't like i i tend to go against the
grain i don't i don't
tend to like uh just follow the same
path because
what's the point it's just like you're
stomping the same ground you're doing
this you're
you're doing the same thing everyone
else is doing it's not really
progressive
i i kind of like things to grow
differently i'm this might surprise a
lot of people but i'm not a big
fan of the way that the world is
and i think this is probably pretty
common uh there's some things that great
that are great technology is great uh
the things we have available to us on a
daily basis are great we've got
computers good food whatever we
basically have whatever we want
and that's all good but there's some
other underlying
problem and i think we see it in things
like
the suicide rate going up and that most
people aren't happy
and things like that but yet we have all
this stuff that's great that
life's better than it's ever been so
that's where the issue kind of comes in
because
now this is kind of hard to express but
i'll just try to be blatant with it it's
like
it's like it feels like everybody's
being rewarded for doing
nothing it's like we get all this nice
stuff and we don't have to do
anything for it and that's depressing
because then it's like
why should i try to do stuff my life's
already great
and then what happens then is your life
lacks meaning
and that's what leads to all the really
bad stuff like depression and etc
is the lack of meaning because why why
would you do it you can go get a
loan and buy the newest iphone and have
whatever sweet stuff there's free
software to do everything
you don't you know it's everything's
already so great
but yet there's no there's no meaning so
i'm continually searching for meaning
all right so moving on to the last
section of this so
what is a new person to do it's really
hard to get feedback as a new creator
you'll have one bitter angry person jump
on every once in a while and say
something obnoxious
that's not really helpful it's really
hard to get critical feedback that
actually
will help you because one person might
say something very valuable and then you
try it and
nothing i don't know then someone might
really criticize you for something and
you might think okay i'll correct that
and then i don't know nothing so
you just kind of get a few things here
and there and you might try them but
they don't actually seem to do any good
so what do you actually do
and i think i've figured this out and i
think it's why i'm
starting to grow more than ever even
though it's still pretty slow it's
faster than before
i've learned a lot and the lessons have
been amazing it's
it's still worth it even just for all
that even if i quit tomorrow
so okay the new person what you should
probably do is focus on making quality
content
and just being yourself with all this
stuff so
quality content and be yourself if
you're trying to trying to be something
you're not that's always
a problem man well i say that but i
don't really know because
maybe if i played some character that
wasn't me maybe things would
grow faster i see even i don't know what
to do
this is the point here and any big
person that's already making it will
can make these type of videos and tell
you what you need to do
but those don't work either because
hey you're not them and b you haven't
had a breakout role you need some kind
of breakout role
they've already had theirs thus they can
go make the video to say here's what you
need to do
have a breakout role and then you're
you're
off to success from there but whatever
you have no way of getting that break or
roll or what if you
keep trying for and it just never
happens
then what that's the things
that nobody can even tell you it's
almost like you have to get lucky
or i guess what you can do is get a
shout out from someone who's already
made it get a shot
all it took was some guy that's already
made it to say go look at them
and then i auto make it all my previous
work didn't even matter all i had
oh god and even all this is subjective
because
in short if you're a new creator it's
almost impossible to grow
fast enough to actually make it
you basically have to give up and go do
something else
unless you get lucky and get a shout out
or breakout role
and you don't really have control over
those
not much anyway doesn't seem like so
that's the video hope you enjoyed
consider supporting me
and i'll see you in the next video
peace out